[Music]
in our previous video we learnt a
fertilization process and what it leads
to the process helps in the formation of
fruits and seeds enclosed in them the
seeds are the structures containing the
embryo within now all that's required is
proper routing of the seeds in the soil
this will result in germination and does
growth of a new plant but not the
question arises how are these seeds
fixed in the soil do they always get
rooted near the parent plant from where
they arise or sometimes at distances as
well seeds can be dispersed to nearby or
distant places as well all thanks to the
process of seed dispersal the process by
which seeds are dispersed to distant
places by various agents is known as
dispersal of seeds who are these agents
seeds are transferred to various places
by factors such as the wind water
explosion and animals these agents make
the process of dispersal of seeds easier
let's now discuss about this process in
detail our first agent of dispersal is
the wind seeds of plants like dandelions
have parachute-like
or hair like structures attached that
are so light and weight that they easily
get carried away by the wind does even
the seeds get carried to distant places
what does the next agent we have in our
list
its water fruits which float such as
those of the Lotus and coconut palm are
carried by water you won't believe that
coconuts can travel for thousands of
kilometres across seas and oceans hard
to believe but they do what is the next
type of dispersal let me name it for you
it's called the dispersal by explosion
did I just say explosion you heard me
right then what exactly explodes in a
plant in some cases fruits the pods
containing seeds burst on their own the
pods dry and split open suddenly with
considerable force which throws the seed
at
since what are the examples of such time
we have plants like broom and piece
which belong to this category now these
were all the abiotic agents last on the
list are the biotic agents which we need
to have a look at biotic needs living
organisms so our animals also
responsible for dispersal of seeds yes
they are
tell me one thing what do we do with the
seeds after eating juicy fruits we
generally throw away the seeds right yes
that is how seeds from a plant growing
in one area reach a completely different
area plants are even benefited with a
seed dispersal by animals to understand
this let's take the simple example of
birds birds also relish on the juicy
fruits that have seeds within in many
cases the seeds of the plant are too
tough to germinate if planted directly
into the soil
now if such a fruit is consumed by a
bird then the seed does not get digested
in the bird's body and is thrown away
directly however the hard seed cover
softens a bit due to the chemical
activity of the acids present in the
bird stomach so as the seed passes
through the birds gut it gets soft and
when it drops in the ground and gets
rooted it becomes easy for the seed to
germinate this is how animals can help
in far and wide dispersal of seeds can
you name some seeds which belong to this
category blackberry cherry apple and so
many pulpy fruits have seeds that are
dispersed by animals now tell me why do
we need this dispersal process I mean
what will happen if the seeds from the
parent plant get planted near it Mania
the parent plant puts severely affect
the growth and development of both the
plants and why so the two will start
competing for sunlight and water that is
the reason why seed dispersal is
extremely useful for plants
[Music]